Alright, this is step number four, Meetings, the core of a product.
What do we need to create?
We need to create a meeting.
We already done it in a previous step.
It works perfect.
One is Schedule Meeting for a Future.
Do that.
Schedule Meeting Add to Calendar.
When I pressed on Schedule Meeting Add to Calendar, my Google Calendar opens.
I have a meeting with Evgeny.
I have a link for the meeting.
I'll try to use the link from calendar.
Join the meeting.
I see all the steps to configure my microphone and camera.
I skipped it.
And join the meeting.
I see the pop-up.
Don't forget to invite your friends for your guests.
I see the copy link button.
I'll copy the link.
And join it.
Я отправлю ссылку на Оскар.
Попробуем.
Давайте мутим нашу микрофону в Discord,
чтобы мы можем поговорить в митинге.
Да, вы слышите меня?
Следующий шаг – это микрофон и камера.
Это должно быть легко.
Я включаю микрофон.
Микрофон работает.
Попробуем.
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
Все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все, все.
"End Meeting for Everyone", and that doesn't work, it works for the third time or with a big delay.
"Pre-join Setup", what's that?
Ah, yeah, we already made this part, it works well.
"Meeting Management".
Let's go back to the meeting.
Yeah, same one.
So, the next step is "Being a Participant".
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
Я не вижу ни бутон, чтобы его дать ему роли.
Я не могу кик Оскар от этого.
Нет, нет бутон.
Я не могу кик Оскар.
I'll try to remove Oscar from a meeting.
That works.
Oscar removed, left our meeting.
Okay, this meeting is finished.
I'm leaving this meeting.
There is a limit in 40 minutes for the basic tariff.
We don't need to sit 40 minutes for that.
I think it's a good idea.
I'll create a new meeting link.
Loading takes a bit five seconds.
Когда я приглашаю на объединение, это занимает около 5 секунд.
И теперь я в объединении.
Но я не вижу никакого кнопка.
Я видела на пункте, я увидела ссылку на объединение.
Сделал это на Оскар.
Также на пункте я увидел все, что можно помочь камеру, микрофон, speaker, видео, квалификацию.
Добавил субтитры DimaTorzok
Немного дворца.
Нет, все будет право.
Окей, разум.
Я вижу эмоции.
Я вижу Оскар срекции.
И...
Мы закончили с этой часть.
Это было часть номер...
4.
Мы можем...
Мы можем закончить эту часть без линии.
Но мы не оставили в этом месте.
Таким образом мы просто снимаем.